e
e e
okay
folks two very quick announcements
before uh I get started one is um some
of you might have got an email this
morning about your company not being on
the master list so I did go through the
master list and you've all told me
you've already picked a company so I'm
sure this is just an oversight so there
are like 20 people without company names
I just sent an email out saying I'm sure
you've just forgotten to do this but if
you're having trouble getting on the
master list let me know because if you
don't have a Stern email address it
won't even let you get on the Google
shared sheet and so you got to find your
Stern email address second announcement
is about the
quiz which is a week from
today it's in the first 30 minutes of
class I want to be very clear so if
you're going to be late that's not the
DAT to be late on because that'll mean a
big chunk of the quiz goes by it'll be
open book open Notes but open notes in
the 2025 version of open Notes digital
iPad you know so you can even open your
laptop if that's where you have your
slides you just can't open up Excel and
work on it not because excel's going to
help you that much but because I can't
have 200 computers all trying to juggle
for time and space and you know making
noises so it's open book open notes and
it'll be you just write your answers on
the quiz and if you've looked at past
quizzes you know exactly what the quiz
will look like right so there'll be no
surprises no need to memorize equations
but you do need but don't assume because
it's open book open notes that you can
come to the quiz and look for
things 30 minutes is not a long time so
if you're looking for a page in the
lecture notes because you don't even
know what the the topic is you will
never finish right there is no time
crunch you know to the extent that I
mean I've tested the quiz out and know
the Tas I've tried it out myself so
basically we double the time and see if
in fact you can get through so there
shouldn't be a time crunch but that
doesn't mean that if you're looking up
stuff that you will not have a time
crunch any questions about the quiz okay
so the quiz will be the first 30 minutes
and then the quizzes will get sorted and
then I'll let you in on what happens in
terms of the logistics after that so
today we're going to you know start on
our journey because this process of
looking at risk-free rates and betas and
Equity risk premiums was to get to a
hurdle rate right a number so today I
want to bring them all into completion
so we start with the risk free rate
right Leon remind me again how you come
up with the risk free
rate depends on the currency you pick if
it's US Dollars you might pick the
treasury and hope and pray the US
Treasury is not default free if it's
some of currency you might have work to
do the risk-free rate is in the currency
of your
choice the equity risk premium reflects
where you do business right so you're
doesn't matter where you're Incorporated
and the beta
up till now at least you know at least
in an unsatisfying way we we came up
with running a regression the slope of
the line was the beta for the moment
let's stay with that beta you know even
though it doesn't seem like a great way
of estimating what the beta of a company
should be so for Disney in November of
2013 here's what the numbers look like
first if you look at the the risk free
rate 2.75% the US 10year t- bond rate in
November of 2013 as I do this calcul
in your head I wanted to think about
what those numbers would look like if
you did them today right T bond rate
then was
2.75% the equity risk premium reflecting
where Disney did business remember 82%
in the US 18% of the rest of the world
was
5.76% and the regression beta was
1.25 let's put all the numbers together
risk free rate plus beta times Equity
risk premium gives me a cost of equity
or an expens expected return of
9.95% this is something you do add
nauseum in any foundations class
risk-free rate I want to put some flesh
on this number so here's the first thing
I want to think about let's suppose
we've all gathered together we've done
the number crunching we've come up with
99.95% you are potential investors in
Disney so you're a potential investor in
Disney it's November of 2013 I want you
to tell me what the
99.95% will tell you as an investor so
as I read these statements if that is
the statement that you would agree with
just just pick that 99.95% of the return
I can expect to make in the longterm on
Disney if the stock is correctly priced
and the capm is the right model for risk
how many qualifiers did I put in there
let's go through it's expected so no
guarantees in the long term so don't
come to me next year and I didn't make
99.95% if the stock is correctly priced
if stocks are mispriced the whole the
all bets are off and the capm is the
right model for risk when I add this I'm
a lazy person when I'm adding this many
qualifiers you know why I'm doing it
right because I want to get to a true
statement so that in fact is one way of
describing the
99.95% but it's a very you know it's an
unsatisfying way because you add all
these qualifiers that's a return so let
me give you another statement you tell
me whether this is something you might
agree with as well right 99.95% is the
return I need to make on Disney as an
investor to break even on my
investment it sounds like I'm getting
greedy right he saying why 9.95% why not
just the risk free rate why not just the
risk free rate Derek why do I need to
make 99.95% to break even the risk free
rate is only 2.75%
% you have the added risk right if I
wanted to make 2.75% I'd buy a t-bond
you made me byy Disney stock it's
riskier I need to make this return to
break even given the risk in the
investment both these statements are
true the first is how a person in
efficient markets where markets work
perfectly would describe the
99.95% but if you wanted to take a more
activist view of that number that's the
number you need to make so both
statements are true but very different
perspectives so let's say you decide to
do your own research on Disney you
collect the data on the management the
projects you look at the cash flows the
earnings and based on your assessment
you think you can make a 12 a half%
return Patrick help me out here you need
to make 99.95% on Disney to break even
you think you can make 12 a
half% what does it make Disney a buy or
a sell
a buy because you can make you can see
already that without an expected return
you can't tell me what to buy or sell
the reason I bring that up and I'm
constantly running into equity research
analysts who tell me I don't believe in
the capm I don't need an expected return
how the heck do you decide whether a
stock is a good investment or a bad
investment without without a threshold
I'm not stopping you from picking stocks
you can pick stocks all that the capm
gives you is the return you need to make
to break even and the riskier an
investment the more I need to do to to
earn to break even we're getting closer
to a hurdle rate the regression beta
still troubles me and I'll give you a
way around it but that's why we compute
this expected return so from an investor
perspective you can see why this number
matters it is the number you need to
make but let's look at it from the other
side I'm the CFO of Disney you're all my
potential investors
you need to make 9.95% not even to be
happy just to break even you supply what
capital to me Equity or debt you're
buying shares you're supplying Equity
this is now my cost of equity your
expected return is an investor becomes
my cost of equity you saying what if I
don't like it I raised capital from you
if that's your expected return I need to
try to deliver it which means if I'm
looking at projects at Disney
collectively those projects need to earn
a return on the equity I invest in those
projects that exceeds
9.95% you see how we're tiptoeing
towards a hurdle rate the 99.95% becomes
a collective hurdle rate for everything
put together later we'll come back and
talk about individual projects but as a
company I need to earn a return and
Equity that exceeds the
99.95% a few years ago I was trying to
explain this to a CFO of Family Group
Company in
Asia so I went through a cost of equity
calculation risk free rate beta risk
premium came up with the cost of equity
of 14% on one named the currency and I
said you need to make a return Equity
collectively as a company it exceeds
14% And then he asked me a question I'd
like one of you to help me answer the
question he said what if I don't deliver
that
14% you see what the when you borrow
money and at 8% you don't deliver the 8%
what happens you go bankrupt you get
into trouble his question was I've
raised Equity I know you're expected
return was 14% but what if I take 7%
projects Jen what what what does your
response going to be there what's the
cost of not delivering obviously I don't
go bankrupt so explain to me as a CFO of
the company why not making 14% would be
a problem for me
there's risk but in a sense I know I've
just raised your Equity already I have
your money I'm taking projects that make
less than 14% I'm doing it deliberately
it's not by accident so tell me what the
consequence will be first I my
shareholders is going to be happy with
me or they're going to be pretty pissed
off right so you're going to try the
first thing your shareholders be really
pissed off and then what are they going
to do they're going to get together and
try to replace you and I'm going to
laugh at you I'm a CFO of a family group
company there's nothing you can do to me
my last name is the same name as the
company's name if corporate governance
is weak and this is why we spend so much
time asking where does the power lie if
you're afraid of shareholders here's how
it plays out you don't deliver the cost
of equity you don't go bankrupt but your
stock price drops your shareholders get
pissed off at you and at some point in
time you get replaced but without that
stick you can already see why in many
companies you know the cost of equity
but in a sense you don't care you take
projects that make less than they say I
have your money what are you going to do
to me so as you look at this as a cost
of equity you need that corporate
governance push to get companies to try
to make more than the cost of
equity any questions on
that so what I'd like you to do for your
company is is to print off that beta
page from Bloomberg okay take it through
the process I took Disney through start
with you know the intercept was your
stock a good or a bad investment I not
noticed quite a few of you have I think
there are three inv videas in this class
I think five Chipotle I
can eating a lot of
those quite a few
Starbucks so it's a very consumer
product driven class I want you to think
about you know looking at that
regression you know don't don't
overthink it it's basically a measure of
how well or badly your stock did during
the last two years Last 5 Years start
with that then take the slope of the
line that's a beta but make sure you
check out the standard of the beta to
get get a range on
it you are going to use this as your way
of getting acquainted with your company
I mean the analogy I would offer is this
is like when you pick a new doctor and
they run that panel of blood tests
this is like your F you're not going to
you know diagnose the company with
anything serious yet but you're getting
acquainted with hey was my company good
investment how does it move with the
market what portion of the risk the r
squ what portion of the risk comes from
the market how much is company
specific so now let's build on the state
because if you believe this notion of
risk free rate plus baited time Equity
risk premium as my baited increases for
the company it becomes a more risky
company remember the risk-free rate and
Equity risk premium are kind of given
you can't control them but the B is
going to be a function of what kind of
business you're in let's say you are a
consultant and I am a tech company I'm a
software company my Beta is two my Beta
is actually three I'm a very risky
software company so I come to you and
say I need a hurdle rate because I need
to decide how to pick projects what the
hurdle rate should be you put in a bait
of three
into that equation risk free rate plus
beta time Equity risk premium not
surprisingly you come up with a really
high cost of equity so you come to me
and say your cost of equity is 20% you
pause right there as a CFO does this
make my life more difficult or less
difficult why because I have to find
projects that make more than 20% so I
come come back to you with I think is a
normal question that any CFO is going to
answer what can I
do to bring my cost of equity down and
I'm going to argue that at least three
things you can try to do they're not all
sensible things but if your objective is
to bring your beta down the three can
somebody give me at least one maybe even
two of those three Re three things you
can do what can the company do to reduce
its cost of
backing you can always try the Cosmetic
stuff of getting in front of a Bloomberg
changing the starting and the ending
points try to make that's not the path I
want you to go right unfortunately
that's the path that some here FS will
go because they want to just play games
but let's take that to the side I want
you to do something real to bring the
cost of equity down
yes one is if I have any
debt I would you would you like me to
pay it down add to the debt you didn't
tell me which pay it down why because
when I borrow money I make my Equity
riskier right unfortunately it's a
software company what's probably going
to be on my balance sheet very little
debt so that option is off the table but
if you're a telecom company with the
high beta you might yes diversify your
bus that have risk let's take that to
the next pragmatic step to to diversify
my business I'm in the software business
I need to find money to invest in other
businesses right one is I can sell a
portion of my software business and buy
something
safer by doing that what do I do I
reduce the bait of my company I didn't
tell you this was all often a sense I
could go become a uity on the side I'll
get a lower beta but what else comes
with that lower
beta why am I in the software business
because it has great returns danger plus
opportunity right if I want to low on my
bait I can liquidate the entire business
put all my money in TBL become a money
market fund in which case what's my Beta
going to be it's going to be zero but I
learn the table
rate so if your endgame is reducing risk
ask you can try that but there are some
creative ways I can stay in the software
business and make myself less risky how
many of you you know are Adobe product
users acrobat REM
weever there was a time when I used to
have to buy the software every two or
three years it was a software company
that made money with upgrades you had to
pay for
upgrades now if you buy an adobe product
I don't think there's a way you can
actually buy Acrobat at a Dream Weaver
you got to be what what do you have to
do you have to be a subscriber a
subscription based model already you can
see why for a software company a
subscription based model actually
reduces risk because now you have a
model where you get
$79.99 every year rather than wait and
see people will upgrade and to do that
they need money so in a sense you've
made your business less discretionary so
second thing you can do is try to make
your business know safer by either going
into safer businesses or being creative
with your existing business and making
your revenue streams more
predictable there's a third action you
can take and in a sense we're laying the
foundations for what truly drives Paya
if I have a lot of fixed costs as a
company think of what it does to my
earnings it makes my earnings more
volatile right in good times I make lots
of money in bad times I lose a Lo so one
of the things you might ask me means
show me your cost structure what are
your biggest fixed costs and is there a
way we can make them
variable what are some of the ways you
can take a fixed cost and make it
variable let's be creative what could
you
try what leasing is still going to be a
fixed cost right it's a fixed lease cost
but what what is outsourcing do I'm not
again suggesting it's a it's a good
thing to do but what does outsourcing do
it takes a cost used to be a fixed cost
and makes it a variable cost of course
there's a tradeoff you no longer control
the process you could try Outsourcing
you can try for more flexible contracts
so when you negotiate with employees for
their you might offer them higher wages
in return for flexibility if things
don't go well that you can lay off
people reduce your
cost it's it's a process that for the
last three decades you've seen at
companies in the US and globally trying
to make their cost structures more
flexible but the end game here is if you
focus on reducing Bas I can tell you
ways of getting there but he says should
I do that it's a different question
right it might be better to stay a high
beta company with a high cost of equity
and go out and pick the best projects
you
can and if you look at the great company
the companies that are doing well out
there in terms of market price most of
them are risky
companies most of them are unstable
predictable earnings but they're still
able to deliver returns that exceed them
so given a choice of being in a risky
business and earning High returns and
equity and being in a safer business and
ending up with low cost of equity you
might pick the first over the second
because ultimately this is about
creating
value now before I actually dig a little
deeper into what drives betas I want to
complete the beta Pages for my other
companies I did Disney in detail but I
want do the other companies in as much
detail because it'll be excruciatingly
boring so what I've done here is taken T
Motors again I went to Bloomberg as I
said Bloomberg is very parochial it
estimates the bait of aard Motors
against the sensex and already we're on
shakier ground in terms of the index why
because it's not that I you know it's
not again that I am when I look at the
S&P 5 I'm attached to it as a US index
I'm attached to it because it has 500
companies in the
there isn't an equivalent index in India
that I can latch on to with any history
the sensex has been around a long time
but it's not a wide broad index but
we'll take it for what it is let's read
what the regression tells us first if
you look at the slope of the line the
raw beta is
1.83 so to the extent that I trust this
regression it's telling me that tarda
modage is 1.83 times more risky than the
typical Indian company but if you bring
in the standard error which is
is16 the range on that bait is 1.67 to
1.99 95% you're going to go to 1.53 to
2.14 so essentially plus or minus two
standard
errors if you look at the r squ
69% 69% of the risk and T Motors comes
from the market the remaining 31% comes
from the fir and again reminding you
what what that means if you diversify
the 31% should go away the 69 % will
stay the Jensen's alha The Intercept is
2.28 and remember what I said about
Bloomberg intercepts are pretty sloppy
about decimals and percentages that's
2.28% you subtract out the risk free
rate which in Indian repe was 4% on
average but remember because it's a
monthly regression I divide by 12 to
make it a monthly risk free rate the
Jensen's Alpha I come up with on a
monthly basis is 2.56%
that's every month you make 2.56% on an
annual basis that number is going to
become 35.42 per. so if I asked you was
to T mot is a good investment between
2009 2013 the answer is
absolutely if you'd own TARTA Motors all
the way through you'd have benefited but
there's no way you can go back in time
and make that but when you see a Jensen
Al of
35.42 just like with Disney of 9.02%
it's worth stopping and asking the
question why what did they do that
allowed them to deliver this
35.4% they might have gotten lucky being
in a sector that took off but out motiv
that wasn't the case the average
Jensen's Alpha for automobile companies
in that period was close to zero the one
action that they took during this period
that really made a difference to them
was the acquisition they made of Jaguar
Land Rover and normally Acquisitions are
valued destructive it's among the most
value destructive things companies do
you saw the Sterling Drugs Eastman Kodak
acquisition you're saying what
made the tarda motors acquisition of
Jaguar Land Rover pay off so well first
in an acquisition it's nice to find the
right
seller you know who owned Jaguar Land
Rover in
2009 who do they who did T motus buy
Jaguar Landover from they bought it from
Ford
Ford in 2009 was desperate to get rid of
stuff off the balance sheet why because
you'd come off the 2008 crisis GM had
already gone under Ford was on its way
they said we want to get rid of Jaguar
Land Rover at any price if you're ever
going to buy something find somebody who
says I will sell it to you at any price
and take them up on their word because
they effectively gave away Jaguar Land
Rover for a
song TARTA Motors has been saved by that
acquisition ever since and you saw in
the first 5 years the payoff from having
bought Jaguar Land Rover at a really low
price it's not that they bought Jaguar
Land Rover per se but that they bought
it at a really low price so when you do
this for your company and you end up
with a really big positive Jensen alpha
or big negative Jensen Alpha don't think
of it just as a number do a little
digging to see what might have caus it
so if you're doing Starbucks what do you
think the Jensen Alpha is going to look
like for Starbucks right now you reading
the news
stories it's a company with a broken
story right it's a company that is in
trouble how do we know it's in trouble
it's had what two CEOs kind of rotate
through a new CEO the Chipotle guy is
now in charge clearly something is
broken in the model and if any of you
get a Starbucks you can see what's
broken every time you walk into a
Starbucks right I haven't stood in line
to order a Starbucks in Forever because
I ordered online and when you go and
what do you see you see 50 people
waiting for their online pickup orders
and two for La people sitting in the
Starbucks for which Starbucks pays how
much for those those
stores the original Howard SCH idea of
Starbucks being a cafe where people
gathered and ordered customized drinks
and I know had a good time it's kind of
broken and I'm not sure how you bring it
back together the market recognizes that
so if you look at at The Last 5 Years
you're probably going to get a negative
gensen alha and you want and there
you're going to talk about what's so
with all of these things and not just in
this part whenever you get a number
don't stop at the number dig a little
deeper and give it some flavor by
looking at what's causing the number to
be what it
is finally I decide to get an expected
return in rupees why because I wanted to
I wanted to do everything in rupees and
if I do everything in rupees I need a
risk free rate in rupees I know it's
been a while and you probably don't
recognize the
6.57% but my risk free rate in rupees is
not the Indian government bond rate
which was
8.82% it was that number minus the
default spread and you're going to see
in a minute why I need to do that I end
up with a risk free rate in rupees of
6.57% the beta at least of our trust is
regression is 1.83 and the equity risk
premium is the weighted average equity
risk premium of the parts of the world
that TARTA Motors operates in and
remember China and India very close to
each other 23.6 versus
23.9% again the same template that I'm
using for Disney what does that mean if
I buy tarda Motors as an invest as a
potential investor I need to make
19.73%
to break even in repeats could have done
this entirely in US
Dollars which case what would be
different first if I do the risk fre
rate it has to
be the US bond rate right which would be
much lower I'd get a lower expected
return in Indian rupes in US Dollars
than in Indian rupees because I'm
working with a lower inflation
currency and if you are intimidated by
the 19.73%
estimate the expected return for a
Turkish company in Turkish
L your cost your required return will be
30 31 32% not because you're greedy but
you start with 16 18% inflation you need
to make 30% just to break
even so that's a to to motus calculation
any
questions
yes
yeah we come to that right that's
basically if all here we're just focused
on bait and cost of equity but you're
you're raising an interesting point
Point your endgame as a business is to
not minimize your cost of equity but
your cost of capital and I think you're
raising an interesting point of if I
take away all debt my cost of equity
will be lower but my cost of capital
might end up being higher because I've
replaced cheaper debt with more
expensive Equity so that's why I said
each of the pathways I'm suggesting here
is not exactly the way I would suggest
they go but when companies get entirely
focused on minimizing their beta they're
going to do exactly what we describ
right you're going to try to focus in on
just the equity it's not good for the
company but you can see why that Focus
drives your
decisions let's take v v had two
choices I could run the regression with
v the domestic listing in Brazil in
which case no regression is against the
basa right and the and the beta that you
get is about
point it's less than one at 089 or I
could take an ADR adrs as I said are
listings of foreign stocks in the US
where everything is in dollars it's
easier to trade if you're a non-
Brazilian investor to buy the ADR and if
you ask for a regression beta for an ADR
Bloomberg being Bloomberg says it's a US
listing we're going to run it against
the S&P 500 and the beta that I get is
1.37 now the amount of angs people get
when they get these two betas which one
should I
use I think Shai is shy
here Shai actually ran the regression
against the S&P 500 the msci and he said
which and the answer is they're both
crappy numbers right they have big
standard errors I can give you pluses
and minuses again I'm digging that hole
for regression betas even deeper right I
can run this against two indices I get
different betas I don't trust either of
them but you're going to get very
different regression Diagnostics if you
pick one of these regressions so if if
you're doing a company like V where you
have multiple listings pick one now
maybe pick the domestic listing do the
regression Diagnostics holding your nose
while you do it because you say I don't
trust this number I don't trust this
number I don't trust this number you're
right I don't trust the number either so
we'll talk about replacing the
regression beta but it kind of gives you
insight into how your choices can drive
what you end up seeing as the beta for
your
company but do actually ran a regression
against the Dax that was there the
default but then I reran the regression
against the footsy why cuz this is in
1999 in 1999 German investors invest in
German stocks French and French stocks
with the EU basically already have
investors investing across borders You
could argue that no no European stock
should have an regression against the
domestic index at least in the US there
are a lot of us domestic investors who
invest only in US companies but in
Europe increasingly your investing
across the Euro Zone but you can see
very different numbers for The Intercept
of the beta and for
Buu I ran the regression against the S&P
500 because it is a NASDAQ listed stock
but the truth is if there had been a
Chinese listing and I'd run it against
the shenz and that I've got a very
different number I did run a regression
against the NASDAQ using a lot you know
I think a a logic that you would see
some in analyst use it's listed on the
NASDAQ so why not regress it again
against a
NASDAQ the problem though is when you
regress it against a NASDAQ what you're
getting is a regression against a tech
index the nature of bet is shouldn't be
against your sector it should be against
the entire
Market part of the reason we stay with
the S&P 500 even though we might be
looking at a Google or a Microsoft which
might be NASDAQ listed stocks is because
the NASDAQ is almost entirely a tech
index you want broad Industries to keep
with the tenor of what you're trying to
estimate which is what is the risk added
to a diversified
portfolio so now I'm going to return to
what we started with ear at the start of
the session now when you when we started
with betas I made it look like a
statistical number right Runner
regression the slope of the line is bet
because that's how I was taught betas I
want to step back because we've already
started that process with that example
of a beta of three and what do you do
and look at what it is that drives betas
and I'm going to use five companies and
this example is dated because some of
these companies have moved on they've
shifted but with each company I want you
to stop and think about why the company
has the baa that it does not using a
statistical rationale but an economic
one so let's start at the top
Bulgari why do you think Bulgaria is
such a high
bet what does Bulgaria
make things that none of us needs or
wants but we feel the urge to buy it
because we have a lot of money it is a
luxury product that you buy because
you're feeling flush with cash it is an
ultimate discretion you're going to see
this word it is a very discretionary
product and when you have a very
discretionary product in Good Times you
sell a lot in bad times people go to
Canal Street and buy a
knockoff your revenues drop through the
floor you'd expect it to have a high
beta because of what it does Quest
Communications telecom companies telecom
companies tend to have high betas
but it's not for the same reason that
Bulgaria does right because let's face
it Telecom services are pretty
non-discretionary at least at this point
in time we need the Wi-Fi we need our
cell service but telecom companies have
two things working against them that
push their Bas up what's the
first and but technology in you could
invest in that technology there's a big
infrastructure investment lots of fixed
cost right
those big cell towers that cost tens of
millions hundreds of millions not to you
know and and with all the regulatory
cost you got to go so lots of fixed
costs and on top of that what do they
have that they've added to those fixed
cost how how do most telecom companies
fund themselves with a lot of debt I've
never understood this actually I do but
they borrow money and they add on top of
the fixed cost which kind of violates it
principle you have a lot ofix fixed cost
don't add to those fixed costs you
saying why did they do it because AT&T
did it 100 years
ago but there's a difference between
AT&T borrowing money to buy the original
phone infrastructure in the early part
of the
1900s and telecom companies today
putting up towers and what's that big
difference between why was AT&T able to
get away borrowing money on top of fixed
costs Kelly what what was AT&T building
into that allowed them to do
it in fact Congress actually helped them
out they made them a monopoly in fact
one of the first law in the
1916 Congress actually effectively gave
Marbel the Monopoly so you were building
into a monopoly see you see the
advantage of building into a monopoly
you have lots of fixed costs and a lot
of debt but what you're planning to do
is you're going to pass it on to
customers AT&T was building into a
monopoly borrowed money and was able to
get away with it do you think Verizon is
building into a
monopoly Verizon is actually in a
technology business where tomorrow
starlink or some satellit bait system
could take away their entire business so
what does that mean if you're a telecom
company today living in the world you're
in with the competition you have you
shouldn't be borrowing
money he saying but they do they do
because that's what's always been done
and this is why I want you to look at
your company say said that doesn't make
sense and don't let yourself say I'm not
a finance person you don't have to be a
finance person know that if you have a
lot of fixed cost and you put a lot of
debt on top of it and you're building
products into a competitive Marketplace
you're in a sense asking for trouble
Airlines have the same problem they have
a lot of fixed cost they borrow money on
top of that maybe there's time to revamp
how these businesses are funded because
they might be doing the wrong things
given their
profile
Microsoft and I did the BET of
1.25 and this was before a you know the
cloud business and before the AI
business I've been tracking Microsoft's
beta since 1986 when it started small
application software company fighting
against a giant IBM we didn't know
whether it had a really high beta what's
changed first its product base has
widened right the windows it's got
office it's clients are now much broader
than they used to be consumers
businesses and the second thing that
Microsoft had done was it it accumulated
immense amounts of cash you saying why
does that matter what's a bait of
cash zero so as a company as you
accumulate cash it almost like know acts
like an anchor on your beta pulling your
beta down so as companies accumulate
large amounts of cash and many of these
technology companies are 80% technology
20% cash that ba that cash operates as
as as a fact of pulling the betas
down and this was the old G not the
zombie G that you see around this was g
at its peak you know what businesses G
was in actually question you have to ask
is what businesses was it not in in like
26 different businesses appliances
aircraft Services
Capital it's a classic conglomerate
right what should the beta of a
conglomerate converge
towards it should be towards a market
the beta should move towards one the
only reason G's beta stayed above one is
the biggest part of G for much of its
glorious
life was g capital between 1986 you know
ja that was the big bet Jack wch made
you think so what g capital brought a
lot of debt into the process that Deb
operated as a ballast pushing the beta
keep going Exon Mobile beta 70 you think
Oil Company think lots of risk right but
what's the risk that Exon Mobile is most
exposed
to it's the only risk
actually is what happens to oil prices
right Exon Mobile you you know if you
ask me who the CEO of Exon Mobile is my
response is I don't know and I don't
care you're making a bet on oil on Exon
Mobile he's saying but that's risky so
when oil prices go up Exon Mobile's
earnings go up and oil prices go down
Exon that should make it risky but
remember beta measures risk added to the
market if as oil prices go up oil
companies do well what happens to
Airlines when oil prices go up they get
squeezed there are big chunks of the
market where oil is a cost not a revenue
so if your biggest risk is moving in the
opposite direction of the rest of the
market you could end up with a low beta
or you could even end up with a negative
beta this is every investment Banker's
favorite question for MBA so let's let's
play it through can a beta be negative
yes and it's kind of mindboggling right
if a beta is negative what happens the
expected return on the
stock risk free rate plus beta times
Equity risk free right you put in a
negative beta your expected return is
going to be lower than the risk rate say
why would I invest in a stock or in any
investment and earned less than the
expected return there are very few
companies on the S&P on on the US
exchange with negative Bas the ones that
used to exist used to be gold mining
companies what is it about gold and gold
mining that might lead you as an
investor to buy stock in that company
even though the expected return is less
than the risk
rting it's insurance right the keyword
is you buy insurance what does that mean
I'm going to ask you to pay a price you
want insurance it's insurance against
inflation you want that insurance of the
bulk of your portfolios is in financial
assets and you buy gold or gold mining
stocks you're buying insurance against
inflation and the way it's going to cost
you is you settle for an expected return
that's less than the risk
rate there are people out there who
believe in gold as an investment
passionately and that's that's a problem
because they don't just want you to add
gold to a portfolio what do they want
you to do sell everything and buy gold
it's a horrifically bad investment in
the long term over the last 350 years
and we have gold prices going that long
the expected return on gold has been
about 2 to 3% roughly the inflation rate
you seeing that's terrible not if you
have it as an add-on investment but if
all your money's invested in Gold I can
safely predict that 60 years from now
you're going to look back and say I wish
I had done that but but then it's going
to be too late so if any of your
relatives are gold
bugs listen to them but don't act on
what they ask you to do because they're
always on they're very paranoid people
they're convinced that the world is
ending any moment
now but if you have Bitcoin Enthusiast
they're not that different either
Bitcoin is just Millennial goal so
basically the you know let them talk to
each other now maybe they can convince
each other to take half the money in
gold and half in bit coin so when you
think about beta think of it as added
risk and you can see the Pieces come
into play so let's pull together the
pieces that drive beta first is you tell
me what you do as a
company I can already start to guess
whether you should have a high beta or
low
beta so you picked a company right what
what's your company shro discretionary
non-discretionary
you get the car out there you better not
be discretionary you don't fill the gas
tank up you said Chevron right yeah I'm
going to need the gas right maybe if I
have an electric car I don't but the
power that powers the electric car has
to come from a power station somewhere
which is probably also fossil fuel
driven let's face it we might and
mourn about fossil fuel companies we say
they're terrible
companies but they're going to have
Lowes who you doing Leon ADP that's it
interesting what does ADP
do it's a business services company
right in fact if they stop doing it your
paychecks won't get go out your internal
processes break down as a business
product it's pretty non-discretionary
you're not going to cut your ADP
Services if you're in trouble you might
cut off those other things that you do
gain low beta who are you
doing what is what do they do I've never
heard of that
interesting company I it must be a
reason you picked it now we're into
questions like is gaming a discretionary
product or a non-discretionary product I
know many of you have DraftKings on your
phone and you're going to skip your
grocery bill some weeks so that you can
keep betting on draftking so it's an
interesting question is gaming uh you
know but that's the question you need to
ask what does my company do is it
discretionary nonis crry because that's
going to determine whether your company
will have high an average or a low beta
now I'll and there's one sector I think
brings home this concept very simply you
know you take the retail
sector you got luxury retail you got
department stores you got discount
retail you got grocery retail I'll let
you kind of think about the the ranking
think about discretionary
non-discretionary you can already see
the ranking you should get across those
companies now staying on that concept of
discretionary and this might be a
terrible example because phone service
now across the globe has become
smartphones but if you go back before
smartphones there was a time when phone
service in much of the West was
non-discretionary in the US and some
states you had to get a phone so they
could call know Emergency Services if
you needed it but in much of the rest of
the world it was still very
discretionary me at one point time less
than 5% of people in India own phones
the other 5% been waiting for 10 years
to get a phone but that's a different
point the remaining 90% couldn't even
afford a
phone you see why this makes a
discretionary if India does well there's
lots of growth a lot more people become
know move up
from to have enough income and the
bottom line of this is if I compare the
betas of telecom companies in develop
Market
markets to Emerging Markets what should
I expect to
see which which group should have the
higher beta if you if you accept that
starting premise of it being discretion
in emerging markets and
non-discretionary developed markets
you'd expect the bait of telecom
companies in Emerging Markets to be
higher if you go to my web page and I
will talk about using this I report
betas by business I do a global beta I
do us betas I do European betas I do
emerging maret Market betas and for the
most part I go with global betas I'll
talk about why but if you have a
business where you look at the business
say you know what in the Emerging Market
I'm looking at this is not a
non-discretionary product it's a very
discretional product the Emerging Market
betas might fit you better because they
capture the nature of the product in
that so already I want you to stop
thinking about regression Bas and start
thinking about products and services
what does my business do and if you're
actually thinking about about running
this company better you might say what
can I do to make this product less
discretionary the subscription model
something to make your product sticky so
people keep coming back even in bad
times second stop tell me something
about your cost
structure I started this idea with the
example we had when you look at the cost
for a company some costs are fixed costs
and some costs are directly related to
what you sell variable cost if most of
your cost of fixed cost you have higher
operating leverage if most of your cost
of variable cost you have low operating
leverage why does it matter if you have
lots of fixed costs again it just makes
your earnings more volatile because you
got to cover that cost
structure the problem of course is
measuring fixed and variable cost
looking at financial statements is stuff
to do but generically at Le you'd expect
sectors with high operating levels
to have higher betas than sectors with
low operating
leverage I'll give you my favorite
example of a sector which is burdened by
so much in fixed cost that it never has
a normal year it's either going bankrupt
or making billions it's the airline
business think of the cost structure for
an airline what's the biggest single
expense leasing the aircraft right you
got to pay for that on top of that you
have fuel cost and if you're if you're
unionized Airline line you've got
employee costs which are fixed as well
fixed fixed fixed 90% 95% of your costs
are fixed
cost so when you have good times you
make lots of money and bad times you're
going to go
bankrupt but even within the airline
business there's an outlier right it's
the most written about Airline written
about company in case studies ever who
am I talking
about Southwest the template for the
discount until Southwest came along
there were no discount Airlines so let's
think about the Southwest
model does it lease its aircraft yeah
like every other Airline but for the
longest time every Southwest aircraft
was a Boeing
737 you know why they released the exact
same aircraft because it meant less
maintenance Crews less SP they were
thinking in terms of keeping their fixed
cost low fuel
cost I hope Southwest is not economizing
on fuel because I do Fly Southwest
sometimes but they're the only the one
of two airlines in the world the other
is Singapore Air that consistently
Hedges against fuel prices consistently
you say what do the other airlines do
they hedge it exactly the wrong times
they start hedging when oil prices Peak
and they stop hedging when they so but
Southwest does it all the time what does
that give them it gives them more
predictable cost which is one reason
Southwest ticket price prices don't
swing around like United ticket
prices it's a fixed cost but they've
kind of built it into their systems the
airline the ticket prices carry are they
a unionized airline yeah but they've got
the most flexible Workforce ever if you
ever taken a Southwest flight I think
every attendant is also a part-time
comedian maybe if they bring a guitar
they'll be stringing music along in case
you don't have entertainment it's the
only Airline where Steward is check me
on to a flight try that with United you
could be surrounded by 20 stewardesses
and they say I can't do that I've never
done that before it's but here's the
biggest savings you get if you're
Southwest for the longest time this is
starting to change if you took a
Southwest flight out of New York I
remember taking a Southwest flight out
of New York this is 20 years
ago ticket prices were cheap I get the
ticket the day the the day off the
flight I check my ticket to see which
airport I'm flying out of is it JFK is
it Newark is it LaGuardia and it says
ielp so no insult meant to people who
grew up in I slip I had no idea where I
slip was this is town in Long Island I
get into a cab say take me to iip he has
no idea where to go so we kind of
navigate our way we get there it's tiny
little
airport I get on a flight say thank you
God I made that flight and I'm flying to
LA and I'm thinking I'm going to land in
LAX they land and I come out there's a
huge statue of John Wayne in the middle
of the
airport I'm in
Santana for the longest time if you took
Southwest flights they avoided the big
name airports right no ha
Midway what was their rationale for
doing
this how does United controlled Terminal
C and now Terminal
A like 150 g Gates I think they partly
control it for the laughs they fly into
gate 35 and give you a connecting flight
in 143 there's somebody upstairs
watching you on the camera say she won't
make it let's switch the signs on her
it's like comedy acts but the way they
keep those Gates is they have to pay for
those Gates whether one flight goes out
of 15 it's a fixed cost the original
reason Southwest avoided the big
airports is ielp paid Southwest to fly
out VI slip rather than the other way
around it's a tactic that European
discount Airlines have adopted right so
for God's sakes don't take a European
discount airline to Paris you will land
somewhere within 120 miles of Paris
it'll be some airport somewhere really
low fair but then you got to figure out
a way how to get to
Paris every action that Southwest has
taken through its life has been about
keeping fixed cost law and you know how
it paid off after 911 there was a point
in time when Southwest Airlines alone
was worth more than every other Airline
put
together so when you think about fixed
cost that's basically what you're
talking about is but is there a tradeoff
here though Southwest Lo lose some
Revenue because they fly out of ice slip
absolutely they probably also lose those
those those revenues from connecting
flights coming through and they were
willing to accept it so I'm not saying
this is a this is a freeb when you go
for Less fixed cost you're adopting a
different business model but you're also
giving up
revenues so with that in place though if
you ask me to measure the operating
leverage in company I'm going to run
into a problem with the company you pick
pick you know take the most recent
financial statement their income
statement and I challenge you to tell me
which of the costs you see in that
statement are fixed on which are
variable let's go through typical income
statement starts with revenues and below
that is cost of good sold right let's
make a guess fixed or variable probably
variable because it's directly related
and then all bets are off because once
you go below gross profit you have items
like sgna fixed a variable who really
knows you can make a guess and say
mostly fix mostly
variable there is the information in
financial statements is not good in
terms of what's fixed and what's
variable so I'll give you a little trick
that might or might not work with your
company to figure out whether it has
high operating leverage or low operating
leverage remember what you said happens
when you have high operating leverage
lots of fixed cost when your revenues go
up a little your income goes up a lot
when your revenues drop a little your
income drops a lot so when Delta lost 3%
of its revenues was a 45% drop in
operating
profit so if you can take the percentage
change in operating
income and divided by the percentage
change in revenues you getting a rough
proxy for does my company have a lot of
fixed cost or does it have a lot of
variable cost if that number is a high
number percentage change in operating
income is large relative to percentage
change in revenues you have a company
with lots of fixed costs High operating
leverage and this you can you know don't
do it for one year because God only
knows what one year will deliver but if
you do it over enough time you I don't
get I know it's intimidating with that
many numbers but what I did for Disney
is I went back to 1987 and every year I
computed the percentage change in
revenues and the percentage change in
operating income across the entire time
period if you take the percentage change
in operating income and divide by the
percent change in revenues the number I
get is
1.01 in 1996 though Disney did buy cap
cities it changed its entire makeup as a
company so since 1996 that numbers your
first reaction when you look at those
numbers is I don't know whether that's
high whether that's low whether that's
typical so I computed that number for
all entertainment companies so let's
take the 1.25 as a current number for
Disney if the average is 1.15 and
Disney's operating leverage statistic
1.25 it has more fixed cost than the
typical entertainment company right what
does that mean its beta should probably
be a little higher than the typical
entertainment company I'm not going to
get carried away because the difference
between the 1.25 and 1.15 is is so small
that it might be pure statistical noise
but if the number for your company is
2.5 and the average for the sector is 08
you have a company with much more in
fixed
cost if your number is 08 and the
average for the sector is 2.5 very
different cost structure try this out
with
Airbnb and the rest of the hospitality
business the rest of the hospitality
business is hotels with a lot of fixed
cost Airbnb is a technology company it's
a platform in 2020 they laid off 80% of
their employees brought their cost down
because they didn't have the revenues
Marriott couldn't do
that so unless you have a company that's
an outlier I wouldn't get too carried
away but at least you have a statistic
you can track over time to see what's
happening to my cost
structure so what business your in
matters know whether it's a
discretionary or non-discretionary what
your fixed costs are matter because they
drive your beta the third and final
determin into Bas is how much have you
borrowed why does it matter because when
you borrow money you create a fixed cost
you did not have until you borrowed the
money which is interest
expenses when you have interest expenses
if you look at Equity investors in Good
Times you make a lot more money but in
bad times you lose a lot more money it
just magnifies what happens to
equity and with Le with with with with
financial leverage we have a statistic
we can use we can we can measure to see
how much data company has taken on to
the extent that accountants tell us
what's debt on the balance sheet we come
back and clean up for it and we know
what the equity in a company is we can
look at the debt to equity ratio for
your company an intuitive way of
thinking about this statistic is it
tells me for every dollar of equity how
much do I borrow this Statistics should
be in market value DBS because we're
looking at a beta which is a market
number so if a billion dollars in equity
and $500 million in debt your debt to
equity ratio is
50% I'm going to now kind of confuse you
by breaking beta down into two
variant the first is I'm going to call
it a levered beta okay this is the beta
that reflects not just the business
you're in but how much you've taken in
debt but I'm going to create a second
version of beta that I'm going to call
an unlevered beta and unlevered beta is
the beta of the business you're in the
fixed cost you have
so if you start with the unlevered beta
and you know what your debt to equity
ratio is you can estimate what the lever
beta the beta for your Equity will be by
bringing in the effec of debt you're
saying what's is 1 minus t doing in
there what's it doing in there why am I
multiplying the amount of debt you have
by one minus
t because the government kind of puts
its hand over your shoulder saying when
you borrow money we'll be on your side
because we let you claim so it makes
your fixed costs less painful because
they are tax dedu
it's called the Hamada equation for beta
you'll see variance of this equation if
you worked at a bank maybe without the
one minus t know and they're all okay
because essentially trying to adjust the
beta for leverage I'm going to stick
with this one because I know it's a one
that I find most consistent with the
rest of what we're going to do but
essentially the lever beta captures the
beta you will see as an equity investor
and that will reflect not just the
riskiness of the business but how much
debt you chose to take
on but when you ran a regression and we
got a beta just said beta right is a
regression beta a lever beta or an unle
beta Constantine you're what what makes
it lever
though but all I did in the regression
was run regression the Returns on the
stock against returns in the market
index right
okay when you run the regression you use
Returns on a stock and you have a
company with a lot of debt the Returns
on the stock are going to be more
volatile it's kind of sneakes in there
right you didn't even know it was in
there a regression beta is always a
lever beta in fact I can almost
guarantee you that when you see a beta
from a service or beta from a regression
it's always a levered beta unlevering
requires that you work at
it the regression beta we got for Disney
was 1.25 I know we had lots of questions
about it but let's start with that it's
a lever beta but let's step back and
think about what Leverage is built into
that beta to to get that beta ran a
regression Over The Last 5 Years or 2009
through
2013 The Leverage that's built into the
Beta is not the debt to equity ratio
today but the average debt to equity
ratio that Disney had over those five
years so let's say that average was
19.44% and that's observable right you
can look at the debt and the equity each
year the average debt Equity so let me
emphasize again it's so if you went out
and borrowed $5 billion yesterday your
regression beta will not reflect it
because the average debt to equity rati
during the regression I'm going to do
something that's going to look like I'm
creating more work but there's a reason
I'm going to do this I'm going to take
my regression beta and I'm going to
unlever it sounds fancy but when I
unlever it I'm taking out the effect of
debt from this so 1.25 is my lever beta
it's regression beta
19.44% is my debt to Equity the tax rate
I'm using is a 36.1% tax rate which in
2013 was the marginal tax rate that
Disney face we'll come back and deal
with this question of marginal tax rate
what do it measured a little later in
the class but if you work through the
math you end up with an unle beta
1.11 again people go through this
exercise mechanically so I want to put
some flesh on this number again have you
ever seen Jeopardy the show it's a very
strange show me a while to get used to
because the way the Sho the the show
works is I give you an answer and you
got to guess the question you ready
we're going to play some
Jeopardy if the answer is
1.11 what is the question to which it is
an answer and don't say what's the UNL
bet I want something a little deeper
than that right what is the question
that I'm answering you when I say the
with that
1.1 yes
one question I you could ask is what is
the risk of the business not the risk of
the equity what's the risk of the
business the answer would be 1.11 any
other questions to which it's the
answer could Disney have run this
business entirely as an equity funded
company it's it's a choice companies
have right so the second question you
could ask is if Disney had been an all
Equity funded company all the way
through what would it beta be wouldn't
be 1.25 it would be
1.11 the UNL beta kind of latches on to
the risk of the business and if you
think about Bulgari versus Quest here's
where it's going to show up the
unlevered beta for Bulgari will still be
high because your core business is risky
the unlevered beta for Quest is going to
be much much lower because the core
business is pretty safe they've just
chosen to take on a lot of debt there's
one beta in quite touch which was um
Altria Altria of course
is Philip Morris I don't know why
companies even change their names I do
know the name gets toxic you think so
they think changing from Philip Morris
alria takes away the the the taint of
cigarettes but why does Altria have such
a low
beta you really low beta
addicted if I mean don't pick on alria
if credit swets could addict you to
Structured Products would they of course
they would it's every company's dream to
addict you to whatever the product is it
works for Altria we pick on them because
it worked for them it doesn't work for
you but it's a driver of low
Bas
so two questions which and there's
another reason why I unlevered the beta
could can companies change their mind on
debt and increase their debt ratio lower
the debt ratio absolutely
right and now I have a basis for telling
you what the beta will be if you choose
a different debt ratio so what I've done
here is I've taken the debt to Capital
again in all in market value terms from
zero debt zero debt your UNL beta is
your lever beta 1.11 and then I've tried
different debt ratios 10% debt 20% Deb
30% Deb 40% de same business same
project same tee Park same movies all
changing is how much of my Capital comes
from debt let's start with the obvious
effect as I borrow money My Equity beta
the lever beta gets higher not because
the business is getting riskier but
because I've magnified the effect of it
so think of debt as a magnifying glass
basically it takes whatever risk you
have as a company and magnifies
it and as my debt to cap goes up my debt
to equity goes up and getting from debt
to cap to debt to equity is a very
simple exercise if your debt to cap
ratio is 20% you have debt of 20 Equity
of 80 20 divide by 80 is 25% debt to cap
is 30% Deb is 30 Equity is 70 30 by 70
is
42.86% so if you give me the First
Column the second column falls out of it
the debt to equity is what I use to
lever the beta and as I get to 90%
debt or a 900% debt to equity take a
look at what happens to Disney's beta
you're saying Disney with a beta of
7.51 you can take any company and make
its beta 78 or9 if you borrow enough
money you saying who'd be crazy enough
to do it you know what the typical debt
to cap ratio in a leverage buyout
is 80% debt 85 pushing to
90% so if you do a leverage bu I don't
care if you're KKR black you've done all
your homework you you got right after
you've done the Leverage about you're
incredibly exposed right the analogy I
would offer it's like building a home
right on the ocean front in a Caribbean
Island where hurricanes come through
regularly and you have no
windows put in
yet right after you buy the home you
frantically get the windows in hoping
and praying that a hurricane doesn't hit
in the meantime do you see the analogy
here you do a leverage part even if
you've done all of your homework you've
done this right right after the other be
are incredibly exposed if there's a
recession that hits you I don't care how
well you did your homework it's not
going to make it but if you have time
what's your first priority right after
Leverage buy what do you have to
do don't pick projects don't go out your
first focus is to bring the debt down by
doing what by selling assets by using
cash whatever you can because you can't
survive as a business with a debt to
equity ratio of 80 or 90% if you're any
normal business
the only businesses that have debt
ratios that high that survive tend to be
either
utilities or banks with utilities you
can see why right why why can they
survive with with debt ratios that
high and the UNL bait is close to zero
it's not just that a monopoly but they
sell a product you can't live without
right Power Water their UNL betas are so
small that they can go to 90% debt ratio
and the lever bait is still around
one why do banks survive with a lot of
thatt Cu the core business banking
business is actually a very safe
business you take in deposits you lend
it out you had an all Equity funded Bank
its beta would be like
0.152 so historically what have Banks
done they've been able to borrow money
and still get away with
it we'll talk about this later but what
have Banks increasingly tried to do in
the last 40 years partly drawn by greed
and partly by the fact that a for more
being left out they no longer want to do
oldfashioned banking they want to do
investment banking they want to trade I
understand but if you do that what
should you do to your debt ratio as you
embark on these riskier and riskier
Endeavors you have to bring it down but
they didn't why for the same reason the
telecom companies don't then you have
crisis like 2000 say what the heck
happened it's not a question of what the
heck happened why did it take so long to
happen because when you take Risky
Business you borrow them that's
effectively what you're doing
so you'll see this again when we talk
about financing mix so if you want to
minimize your cost of equity it's simple
don't borrow money but if you want to
talk about cost of capital this is going
to become an ingredient into that
process to say what's the right mix of
debt and Equity because it'll tell you
what happens you cost of equity as you
borrow more money so get comfortable
with that Levering unlevering you know
if you have trouble with the order of
operations get over that no because you
know I it's it's again a struggle if you
haven't been around numbers for a while
go through my wife teaches fifth grade
she struggles with her kids getting the
order of operations right but it's
something you forget if you don't work
with numbers and if you get the order of
operations wrong on that levered
unlevered beta equation God help you
you're going to get Strang looking
numbers so work through a few by hand to
make sure you get this
right which brings me to the way I'm
going to get around regression Bas
because by now you can see I'm a skeptic
on Reg ression B I don't like that one
regression one slice of History you can
play games with it so here's where a
property that Bas have that is very
useful comes into play betas are always
weighted
averages weighted by what how much money
you've invested in each asset you have
so let's take a simple example let's say
you run the Fidelity mellan Fund Robert
stansky used to run the fund use was a
Stern MBA from the
1970s F mellan fund is one of the
largest mutual funds in the world
invested what used to be young companies
but now increasingly in kind of tech
companies and growth companies there's
150 companies in its
portfolio you know the beta for the fund
for the fider M mellan fund will be a
weighted average of the 150 bit is
weighted by how much money it has in
each one each of you has a
portfolio I don't know how big the
portfolio is I want to ask you it's
personal but take a look at your
portfolio take a look at what's it what
it's invested
in each of those Investments has a beta
so maybe you're in five mutual
funds you have betas for each fund
you're going to take a weighted average
maybe you have a lot of money in cash in
which case a bet of zero the beta for a
portfolio is a weighted average of the
betas of the Investments that go into
the
portfolio so if this were an Investments
class that's the route we're going to go
but this is a corporate finance class
we're talking about businesses
or companies and I'm going to use the
same principle the beta for a company
should be the weighted average of the
businesses that that company is
in I told you g was in 26 different
businesses if I could figure out a way
to give you the beta for each of those
businesses the bait of a g is going to
be a weighted average of those 26
businesses when you have a merger two
companies coming together it's going to
create a combined company the beta for
the combined company will be a weighted
average of the betas of the two
companies involved in the merger so
we're going to build on this principle
by starting with a merger and I'm going
to go back in time to
1996 when Michael
Eisner decided to buy cap cities to make
Disney a bigger entertainment company so
at the time of the acquisition Disney
had about $3.2 billion in debt and a
market value of equity of 31.1 billion
cap cities had about 615 million debt
and a market value of equity of 18 and
half
billion if you add the debt plus Equity
you get the value of the entire firm and
Disney's total value is 34.3 billion cap
City's total values 19 billion you
saying why do you care about the values
what do we say the beta for the combined
firm will be a weighted average right so
it's good to know that Disney is a
bigger firm Cap City is the smaller the
weighted average is going to reflect
those weights they were both publicly
traded the beta for for uh for Disney
the regression beta is 1.15 the equity
beta and Cap City Equity bet is 0.95
again what do we say those regression
betas are levered or unlever the lever
bait is reflecting the debt to equity of
the two companies and you can see the
debt to equity for Disney is about 10%
the debt to equity for cap cities is
about
3% now I am cheating a little bit
because I'm supposed to use the average
debt to equity ratio over the last two
or five years I'm going to stay with the
debt to equity now and act like it's a
debt to equity over the period so here's
what we're going to try to do we know
these two companies are going to merge
and you're going to have one big Disney
right Cap City is being part of it and
we're going to try to estimate the beta
for the combined company so before we
embark on the numbers given the betas
what do you think the beta for the
combined firm will be at least let's get
a sense of direction will Disney's beta
decrease from 1.15 or increase after the
acquisition because you're buying a b
company with a lower beta it should
decrease unless there's need of does
what it funds the acquisition with debt
and this becomes the wild card right
because you could do this acquisition
end up with a higher beta if you take on
a lot of debt so because debt is a wild
card what I'm going to do first is
estimate what the beta will be for the
combined company without even thinking
about debt and then bring in debt so
that it can keep the two processes
separate so good idea because many of
the quizzes this is a question you you
see where a company does something that
changes the the business and it changes
its debt to equity ratio keep the two
separate first work out what the beta
will be for the business and then bring
in the Deb effect so let's start with
the first and look at the beta for the
combined
company using just UNL betas remember
that's the beta of the business the
unlevered beta for Disney is 1.08 the
unlevered beta for caps cides is .93 so
I'm doing exactly what I did with the
Disney regression beta of unlevering the
two betas so I know the unlever beta for
the two companies
here's a rule that I think will take a
little while to stick but if you if you
keep at it'll stick when you work with
UNL bait is the weights you should use
should be the weights for the entire
business the value of the entire
business the values of the two
businesses 34286 and 19115 give me
weights of about 2/3 and 1/3 and you
work through the unlevered beta for the
combined company is
1.026 Disney is buying a safer business
it's UNL beta decrease is because it's
buying a safer business so now I know
what the unlevered beta for the combined
company will be now to do this
acquisition Disney's got to come up with
$8.5 billion doar right because that's
what cap cities is worth let's work
through some of the ways it could have
done this could it have issued all
Equity yeah and usually this will take
the form of giving shares so if you're
doing an acquisition we you're paying
with shares like they did for you know
for Lucas Films or with Pixar
you could issue 18 and half million
could they borrow the ENT the entire 18
and half billion so think of those as
the limiting cases all Equity all debt
Disney actually borrowed 10 billion and
used 8 a half billion of their own
Equity what happens the 18.5 billion cap
cities Equity you're going to have a
bondfire right after the acquisition
it's going to disappear because there
will be no cap cities so I'm going to
estimate the beta with that actual debt
ratio of the actual debt mix of 10
billion in debt 18 so let's first work
out how much debt Disney will have after
the acquisition incidentally they took
on or you know the cap City's debt so
that doesn't always have to be the case
in this case they took the 615 million
but then if you add on the 10 billion
you end up with 13.8 billion in debt so
after the deal if they borrow 10 billion
the debt will go up to 13.8
billion the equity will be the 31.1
billion plus the 8 half billion in
equity they have to issue so this isn't
cap City's Equity this is their Equity
the equity will become 39.6 billion the
debt to equity ratio would be 34.82357
I actually also looked at what would
happen if they used all equity for the
deal remember that an option they didn't
take this option if they had the debt to
equity ratio would have actually
decreased to 7.66 per. because I used
all equity and the lever bait would be
1.08 I'm going to give you a task that I
would like you to try this is good
exercise for the
quiz if Disney had used 18 and a half
billion in debt to fund this acquisition
rather than the two scenarios will look
at I want you to to estimate what the
levered beta would have been after the
deal you kind of know which direction it
goes but I want you to work through the
mechanics so try 185 billion debt work
out the total debt work out the equity
come up with the debt to equity ratio I
will send you the solution in the email
I sent later today after the class but
take an extra five minutes after class
work it through because it'll get you
more comfortable with the notion of how
an acquisition gets funded can affect
the beta for the company after the deal
but separate out that unlevered beta
effect from The Leverage effect because
they both come into play but if you try
to mix them up messy things end up
happening so always work through the
unlit beta first before you look at the
effect on debt and Equity any
questions okay so let's uh end on that
page when we start back on Wednesday we
will
continue with weighted average bage